sabotage and smear that's the focus of
tonight's angle
now when the Press kept catching LBJ
falsely describing the true state of the
Vietnam war effort it became known as
his credibility gap
repeated Assurance is a progress that
didn't pan out only undermine support
for the war at home
well fast forward now to present day
where another credibility gap is eroding
public faith in almost everything that
our so-called experts are saying led by
of course the establishment of both
parties
last night we blew open the covet lab
leak cover-up where politicians Health
officials academics all refused to tell
the full truth about the origins of
covet and worse than that instead of
holding China accountable
these American officials smeared
American doctors and yours truly and a
few others uh and rather than raising
bloody hell about any of this rather
than demanding answers the Press helps
the fraudsters cover their tracks
now this has led us to a very dangerous
place where large segments of the public
simply won't believe the establishment
on much of anything
and can you blame them
now time it again when our Elites sense
their narrative is about to be split
wide open
they decide to attack the messenger
I don't think I've ever seen a prime
time cable news anchor manipulate his
viewers
the way Mr Carlson did last night
I don't think I've ever seen an anchor
treat the American people
an American democracy
with such disdain
oh the dripping disdain coming off his
lips like Schumer lecturing anyone on
lies and manipulation that is really
rich
he's the one always trying to manipulate
the facts remember even after the
Mueller report came out finding no
evidence of collusion between Trump and
Russia
Schumer refused to rule it out
and of course Schumer repeatedly lied
about Brett Kavanaugh just to try to
keep him off the court
so how does Schumer or any of these
individuals who've LED our country into
a ditch have any standing to claim the
mantle of honesty and integrity over any
issue of significance
I say we need more information released
about all matters of public concern not
less
which is what an honest press used to
demand but now the media Democrats and a
few establishment Republicans You Know
Who You Are
they're all crowing about the release of
January 6 footage
the better question is what were you and
everyone else in power trying to hide
these past two years
was it the truth about your fake
Insurrection narrative
does anyone think that any of these
people were planning or capable of
conducting a coup against the United
States government come on now for months
all the Democrats wanted to talk about
January 6 January 6th they threw in
Charlottesville every now and then too
but now we're apparently supposed to
accept everything they've ever said
about it as the gospel it's all true no
matter what
well that's convenient
yes there were people who broke the law
who were violent and they should be
punished as we said that very night
but there were others who were made
examples of political examples
don't rally for someone like Trump again
you may be arrested for just walking
through an open door and taking selfies
nine o'clock in the morning I am on my
bed doing my emails that I usually do
and I can hear some Ruckus going on in
the other room the kitchen slash dining
room area so I get up come around the
corner and I hear somebody barking hands
up FBI they proceeded to handcuff me
gave me no reasons why of course no
search warrant God forbid they present a
search warrant six o'clock in the
morning I hear Boom Boom Boom Boom Boom
FBI open the door open the door we'll
knock it down one was pointing an
assault rifle at my head about four feet
away and it said please step outside I
stepped outside they handcuffed me I
said what is this about and they said
search warrant they never produced one
they never showed it
and why were the capital police so
unprepared
now Tucker Carlson spoke to Tariq
Johnson a former police officer who was
on the front lines on the capitol on
January 6th the Frontline officers and
supervisors were not prepared for that
at all I ran over to the Senate side to
make sure those doors were locked so I
asked over the radio and I say something
to the effect that
um we need direction we have hundreds of
people inside of the building what do
you want us to do we need some direction
I got I heard no response
no response
and why didn't the House and Senate
leadership act on the Intel agency's
warnings before January 6.
I mean forget Schumer we know what he's
all about why isn't Mitch McConnell
demanding demanding answers here
well he's not instead he hit Fox today
and Mitch wonders why so many working
people don't trust him
why the Republican base doesn't like him
The Establishment has no one to blame
but themselves for the State of Affairs
our nation finds ourselves in whether
it's the CDC the vaccine mandates or the
Pentagon on what's happening in Ukraine
or Biden downplaying inflation
throughout most of 2021
they've fallen into a trap all these
people of their own making
if they're not going to tell us the
truth about China or the true state of
our own economy
why would we trust him on anything else
now recall that without any evidence
many rushed out to accuse Russia of
sabotaging its own pipeline last year
remember it took seven years to build it
we told you that made no sense
well now Intel agencies are finally
beginning to come clean it looks like a
pro-ukrainian group was involved now we
have not heard the end of this story I
promise you that but the White House
they want to kick the can down the road
several European Partners in fact three
of them in Germany Sweden and Denmark
have already opened investigations into
what happened with the Nordstrom 2
Pipeline and those investigations are
not closed I'd have to refer you to each
of those European countries to comment
on on their investigations
but
I mean he's supposed to be kind of
handling the White House briefing room
stuff not the EU briefing room
and that his answer would be truly
insulting to a truly independent press
but obviously that's not what we have
and again lbj's credibility gap
destroyed his administration and caused
Americans to lose faith in the Vietnam
War
today's establishment should also take
heed
for the past 30 years they've gotten the
biggest issues wrong
from welcoming China into the WTO to the
Iraq War to our open borders to the
coveted response to the inflation
explosion
Trump was making real progress across
the board until the pandemic hit
and then the establishment tried
everything to sabotage his agenda and
smear him personally
so squandered credibility is very
difficult to recover from
but instead of lectures and threats and
complaints let's have the truth
if your policies are so great
come on the show come on the angle will
welcome you defend them
but if you can't defend your policies
and you tried to hide the truth from the
American people
you're just feeding the very political
movement that you fear so much and
that's the angle hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else